bienvenidos de nuevo estamos ahora en el
problema número 15 en el problema número
15 y dice cuando son las 12 pm las 12
del día en nueva york y déjame ponerlo
aquí supongamos que estamos aquí en
nueva york este es new york' ok y son
las 12 pm son las 12 pm perfecto esto en
el tiempo estándar del este es decir el
uso horario que están utilizando es el
tiempo estándar del este que por cierto
lo ponen como tiempo del este como 'the
y así lo escriben muy bien
entonces en nueva york que son las 12 pm
en el tiempo del este
y en nueva york son las 12 pm entonces
en san francisco son las 9 am por otra
parte en san francisco son las 9 y m a
esa misma hora en nueva york y por
cierto en san francisco está el tiempo
estándar del pacífico' que por cierto no
abrevian como el tiempo del pacífico ok
perfecto esto es en la ciudad de san
francisco es a la misma hora nueva york
pero aquí en san francisco muy bien es
decir que hay tres horas de diferencia
tres horas de diferencia entre nueva
york y san francisco
un avión sale desde la ciudad de nueva
york a mediodía en la hora estándar de
nueva york es decir en el tiempo del
este entonces este avión va a salir
quién sabe dónde vamos pero va a ir de
aquí hasta alguna parte supongo que va a
ir ese francisco ok y llegas a francisco
sin perfecto este avión va de aquí hasta
acá y llega a este punto y este punto es
san francisco y por cierto
a san francisco a las 4 pm entonces
llega a san francisco a las 4 pm es
decir en el tiempo del pacífico muy bien
este avión llega a las 4 pm el tiempo
del pacífico y si nosotros le aumentamos
3 horas son las 7 de la noche en nueva
york son las 7 de la noche en nueva york
es decir en el tiempo del este
ok perfectos de aquí a cuánto tiempo
hizo de trayecto este avión sería muy
bueno saberlo una vez a este avión
empezó a las 12 y llegó aquí a las 7 pm
en el mismo horario por lo tanto hizo un
recorrido de 7 horas siete horas ok y de
hecho soy un experto en esto porque
trabajo en una empresa que se dedica a
los fondos de cobertura y ahí se
programan un montón de llamadas con los
directivos de otras empresas y bueno
pasa que muchas veces no están en la
misma zona horaria y por lo tanto
tenemos que programar estas llamadas
telefónicas aún
razonable según la zona horaria
correspondiente
así que por esta razón puede disfrutar
un poco más este problema pero bueno
regresemos al problema
si otro avión sale al mediodía pero va a
salir desde san francisco ahora tengo
otro avión aquí sales de san francisco y
va a salir a las 12 del día es decir
sale a las 12 pm tiempo del pacífico
tiempo del pacífico okey va a salir este
avión a las 12 pm que por cierto las 12
pm am si nosotros le sumamos tres horas
digamos al tiempo del este es decir en
nueva york son las 3 pm en nueva york
son las 3 pm este tiempo del este
ok este avión va a salir imagen se hacia
nueva york va a ir a nueva york o que
nos va a llegar aquí a nueva york va a
llegar a nueva york que es este punto de
aquí y dice que le toma el mismo tiempo
de trayecto
lo que nos preguntan es a qué hora va a
llegar a nueva york y bueno si les va a
tomar el mismo tiempo de trayecto es
decir que también va a ser 7 horas va a
ser 7 horas de trayecto y si va a ser 7
horas de trayecto entonces a esto le
podemos dar 7 horas oa este le podemos
sumar 7 horas pero si nosotros lo que
queremos es el tiempo del este entonces
3 pm 7 horas la llegada nueva york a las
10 pm a las 10 pm en el tiempo de nueva
york en el tiempo del este que por
cierto ya está esta es mi respuesta es
el inciso am el sí swan dice que llega a
las 10 pm en el horario de nueva york y
si nosotros quisiéramos saber a qué hora
llega en el horario de san francisco
pues a las 12 pm le tenemos que sumar 7
horas me va a dar las 7 pm para llegar a
las 7 pm en el horario de san francisco
en el tiempo del pacífico muy bien así
es la solución de este problema creo que
no estuvo tan difícil solamente hay que
tener cuidado con no confundirse con
todas las horas tanto del viaje como en
cada uno
las zonas horarias bueno pues vamos a
resolver el problema número 16 déjame
borrar la pantalla y vamos a trabajar
con el problema número 16 bien veamos es
que sigue tiene una figura parecida a
ésta así que vamos a dibujar la tiene
primero un cuadrado más o menos como
éste tiene un cuadrado más o menos así
ok y después tiene dos círculos y tiene
dos círculos el primero es parecido a
éste
parecido a este es algo más o menos así
perfecto y después tiene otro parecido
también a este a algo más o menos
algo más o menos así perfecto y después
de que quitar estos de aquí para que no
te confundas así que déjame borrar todo
esto de aquí y como lo borro ya sé que
voy a borrarlo con esta propiedad va a
ser más rápido se agarró y quito todo
esto primero voy a quitar todo esto
no me sirve y después voy a quitar todo
esto de aquí de hecho espera voy a
quitar todo esto de aquí todo esto de
aquí a esto no sirve y después voy a
quitar todo esto de aquí no espera no es
así y lo voy a quitar desde acá ok voy a
quitar todo esto aquí perfecto esto no
me sirve y nos quedamos solamente con
este ok y qué datos me dan bueno me
dicen primero que este es un punto de
tangencia aquí se tocan estos dos
semicírculos inventando un montón de
puntos me dicen que este punto se llama
p estoy aquí este de por acá este se
llama q este se llama q este tema
r
este se llama r este se llama s este se
llama s y está por último se llama t muy
bien y que me dice el problema bueno que
los doce mil círculos de verde son un
cuarto de circunferencia cuyo centro
está en ese tiempo respectivamente y
tiene un radio uno eso es muy importante
si este es el centro de la
circunferencia y por acá toca la
circunferencia este es un radio y su
radio vale 1 am de hecho déjeme ponerlo
aquí abajo
su radio vale 1 y este pase lo mismo
aquí estás entre la circunferencia aquí
toca la circunferencia y por lo tanto
éste tiene radio 1 perfecto y si tiene
radio uno aquí también toca la
circunferencia por lo tanto aquí hay una
unidad y por lo tanto aquí también hay
una unidad perfecto y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale el área de lo
que voy a asombrar justo ahorita cuánto
vale el área de esto de aquí eso es lo
que me pregunta y bueno para sacar el
área de esto que tengo aquí pues creo
que esencialmente lo que nos preguntan
cuál es el área de este rectángulo que
tenemos de anaranjado y después a esa
área le voy a quitar el área de estos
dos círculos que tengo aquí a ver
primero cuál es el área cuál es el área
y de hecho déjame ponerlo de color
naranja vamos a ponerlo de color naranja
cuál es el área d
de este rectángulo que tengo aquí de
color anaranjado bueno pues la base vale
11 es decir 2 por la altura que vale 1
el área del rectángulo naranja 2 es 2 ok
esto ya lo tengo por una parte pero esto
a esta área total le voy a quitar am qué
te parece si le quitamos en esta área de
aquí y ya estaría acá es más déjeme
ponerlo con otro color le voy a quitar a
este de aquí y estoy acá y bueno para
quitarle este de aquí y estar acá
primero vamos a fijarnos en uno y
primero vamos a fijarnos cuál sería el
área de la circunferencia entera el área
de la circunferencia entera de esta
circunferencia entera la que borra ese
rato o de una de ellas
vamos a ponerlo aquí el área de la
circunferencia pues es pi por radio al
cuadrado pero si tiene un radio de 1
pues entonces el área de esas
circunferencias y de api ahora quiero
que te des cuenta es lo siguiente no me
estoy tomando toda la circunferencia
entera no hemos tomando toda esta de
camps
solamente me estoy tomando un pequeño
pedazo y este pedazo de hecho es un
cuarto
conferencia por lo tanto si primero me
fijo en esta área que tengo aquí estaré
azul bueno pues entonces esa área de lo
que estoy dibujando del color azul pues
sería el área de un cuarto de
circunferencia es decir si esta
circunferencia entera vale pues
solamente me voy a tomar un cuarto de
esa circunferencia es decir y entre
cuatro y bueno si ahora esto le sumó
esta otra parte de aquí que es otro
cuarto de la circunferencia exactamente
igual esta parte de aquí entonces el
área total de todo lo que está de azul
pues sería pi cuartos más pi cuartos es
decir pi cuartos de esta a déjame
ponerlo si me cuartos de esta y pi
cuartos de estar acá ok y pi cuartos más
p cuartos es lo mismo que pi medios que
pin medios ok o dos y cuartos que es lo
mismo muy bien si ya tengo que el área
de lo que está de azul vale y medios
entonces ahora sí ya puedo concluir el
área de lo que está coloreado de
amarillo es igual am
está sonando
es igual a que tengo pues va a ser dos
menos el área de azul que es para medios
dos menos y medios y bueno es decir el
área que tengo aquí de color naranja 2
le voy a quitar el área de azul y esta
es mi respuesta que por cierto es un
escándalo que por cierto es el inciso b
y bueno voy a contestar el teléfono así
que nos vemos mejor en el siguiente
vídeo donde haremos el problema número